sri lanka's capital colombo is in
turmoil after protesters stormed the
compound of president gotabaya rajapaksa
security sources say he left the area
earlier for his own safety public anger
at the country's leader has been mounted
during the country's unprecedented
economic crisis
people are enduring acute shortages of
fuel food and medicines with a country
unable to pay for imports critics blame
the hardships on rajapaksa and his
family who they say are corrupt
meanwhile the prime minister's office
says he's willing to resign
let's now talk to marlon ariya singh
senior assistant editor at the himal
salvation in colombo hello marlon so
tell us the latest
hi
what's the latest marlin
oh uh the latest days we've been getting
uh conflicting reports that the prime
minister uh uh is going to resign uh
because there was an all party leaders
meeting which was held earlier uh headed
by the speaker and uh it was agreed
there that the president must resign and
also the prime minister
uh but we've been getting uh conflicting
reports over the last hour that
the prime minister uh might resign and
uh
then um just now uh it was uh reported
that uh the prime minister uh
uh
has uh decided to resign uh if there is
a uh interim government in place so uh
we are not really sure of what uh is
actually going on
okay we'll be keeping taps on it but
tensions in sri lanka have been high for
months so what do you think caused the
situation to get to this point
yeah as i said earlier i think uh the
ninth day of a month of the month has
been considered to be some somewhat of
uh
a special significance because after the
may 9th protest uh we've had uh the
pm mahindra rajapaksa
and then uh june 9th was the resignation
of uh
basil rajapaksa the financial minister
and uh now so this uh june 9th protests
were uh were organized uh
uh labeling it as like a final push uh
to pressurize the the president uh gotta
be raj bhakti
so this is why we have uh uh
protesters or people from all over the
island coming into uh
the capital uh in a completely
unprecedented manner uh to demand the
resignation of the president and the
prime minister
there clearly is a lot of uncertainty
now where do you think sri lanka is
headed
um
although there's a lot of uncertainty i
think the people are aware that we are
in the middle of a economic crisis uh
and that we are we are i think aware
that uh the next six months is going to
be really really difficult
uh and you know until we uh get the imf
deal in place uh but i think this is for
the people uh it's it's more about uh
voicing their concerns voicing that
descent towards this government and uh
this president and this pm uh so i think
they would uh they're hoping for some
sort of respite and hope so that they
can go on uh
and you know we can see them being
resilient afterwards
okay marlon aria thank you
thank you very much